[Music]
you know sis Mitt Romney trying very
hard to appear human now have you
noticed that I must fool that look I'm
sweating yeah the people in my planet
told me this is how it's done well this
is how he's doing it Mitt Romney is now
trying to deflect talk of his wealth by
describing his grandfather's humble
origins that's what he's doing now yeah
apparently Mitch grandfather came to
this country with nothing but the shirt
on his back and the dog on his roof and
probably hate him yeah pretty it's a
humble simple story
Mitt Romney has launched a new drive to
appeal to Hispanic voters yeah
unfortunately his new slogan is Mitt
Romney I probably employ one of your
cousins believe it said water totally
President Obama working hard now this
campaign is really they're going at it
now President Obama is proposing to keep
student loans cheap as a way to appeal
to college students any if that doesn't
work Obama's going to switch to his
second proposal hey everybody free pizza
in my room
should work Secret Service scandal and
continues yeah Congress now is expanding
its investigation into the Secret
Service prostitution scandal
congressman want to know how could this
happen who was responsible and do those
ladies take discover cards they do not
yesterday was Earth Day yeah yeah and
apparently today has find out yesterday
was Earth Day
[Music]
I don't think one person here knew
yesterday was earth day know someone
there is only a terrarium I did I got
the celebrity dish for you Kanye West is
dating Kim Kardashian and recently
that's my favorite thing gasps of Lord
no God wouldn't allow it or it gets
unholy well it might just be somebody
who thought they had a chance with Kanye
yeah I'm going with the first X no Kanye
West Kanye West is dating Kim Kardashian
and recently had dinner with Kim's whole
family nice yeah
there was an awkward moment when Kim's
parents told Kanye they expect him to do
the right thing and fake marry their
daughter and kid hit the night on video
in Austin settle down
[Applause]
I will clear this room and start again I
swear in Austin Texas at 4:20 p.m. on
4/20 willie nelson unveiled a statue of
himself yeah partly the statute was so
lifelike Willy tried to buy weed from it
he was there for eight hours then he
went to a statue of Ronald McDonald yeah
you all know the dog whisperer Cesar
Millan of course you do did you know
that yesterday was Earth Day
photographer her Cesar Millan is getting
a divorce
apparently his his wife caught him
whispering in their dog's ear guess what
you're not the only [ __ ] in this house
you hear about the Olive Garden the
Olive Garden's in trouble for
accidentally serving rum to a
ten-year-old boy yeah his parents
suspected something was wrong when the
boy yelled out this is very good Italian
food
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]